all right so here's the question
question 30 in this year's HSC exam
which apparently was a bit curly for
some people so they get given a function
and this is an exponential curve um that
negative tells us it's it's a decaying
curve so rather than something like uh
you know a disease that's rapidly
increasing in in case rates this is
something which actually is going to be
decreasing like so so it's actually the
kind of situation you get when it's like
a radioactive substance and it's
decaying getting smaller and smaller and
smaller so that's that part and then
this part over here this is a
trigonometric curve so these are the
kinds of things which oscillate up and
down and up and down and up and down so
um an electrc magnetic wave or a tide
that goes up and down this is the kind
of shape that it makes so what we're
being asked to do is mush those two
things together and they ask us to find
the coordinates of stationary points and
then what this means is don't find all
the stationary points just find in this
little Zone here um and the they've just
named where that zone is okay so to find
stationary points we need this thing
called a derivative so that's taking
this function up here and doing
something which most students should
have found this fairly routine so
there's uh two things like I said being
mushed together one being multiplied by
another so it's a product U * V so
students at this point are pretty
familiar with what we call the product
rule and this is something that's on the
formula sheet so students need to don't
need to memorize this but they can just
give it a go so let's see Mr B you can
pick up for me if I make any obvious
stuff ups but there's V Here Comes u-h
so there's a negative coming out from
there so I'm getting this that look okay
to you there's my U Dash Here Comes
U and then V Dash that's going to give
me cosine okay first line looks okay so
from here I get a result I can tidy this
up which I will in a moment but what
they really want me to do is find out
when this is equal to zero that's what
find the coordinates of the stationary
points means so let's go ahead and tidy
this up a little bit let's see here I've
got a common factor here and
here here and here so I'm doing things a
little bit quickly because I'm just kind
of focusing on the the end goal here so
I'm going to factor that out let's put
that cos x at the front minus sin x at
the back there's the minus sign checking
for any errors good that looks okay to
me so this is our derivative so F ofx FD
is the Der so I want to know when's this
thing equal to zero now I drew these
pictures up here not just to illustrate
to you what are these things but
actually to do something kind of Handy
for the next step right here e thex
that's this shape that I drew before if
this whole thing is going to be equal to
zero then either this part is zero or
this part is zero it's a little bit like
this if I told you hey I'm multiplying
two numbers together and the answer will
be zero at least one of them has to be
zero because no matter what the other
values are if they were big or they were
small you'd never get zero out the end
unless this or this themselves were Z
now when I have a look at this graph can
you see how I've drawn it so it sort of
approaches and gets close but it
actually never reaches this kind of
horizontal axis that axis is zero it
never gets there um it's what we call an
ASM toote there it gets closer and
closer and closer never gets there so
this part here I don't need to worry
about it it will never equal zero I just
have to focus on this part so I'll say
stationary points exist
when this part here cos x that's very
messy minus sin x equal Z there's a lot
of notation and symbols but it's
actually really important to use verbal
communication where important where
necessary so when I have a look at this
how am I going to solve this well I'm
looking between not and 2
pi what's the most obvious way okay well
I might do this I'm going to rearrange
these just a little bit I'll divide
through by C I get this H so this is
equal to one when I've got Pi on 4
or HM what's the next one it'll be 5 Pi
on 4 can I get a check on that Yep looks
good to me so what have I just been
doing I've been trying to solve this
thing in my head I've been changing its
form to to one that I'm a bit more
comfortable with and which students
they'll be familiar with how to do this
process and working out okay this thing
here is another graph this is a question
that's all about visuals right so how
much visual is behind a student's mind
when they're graphing or when they're
solving I should say now even though
this is unfamiliar to you this is a
curve that they've met hundreds and
thousands of times it's a weird looking
thing it looks like
this like so I want to know when this
weird looking thing is equal to one and
it's
here I found the first spot that one
it's Pi on
4 and this next one here 5 Pi on 4 so
those are numbers they look a bit weird
but they are familiar to anyone who's
done the advanced course and gone all
the way through so the original question
did say find coordinates I've got an x
value so what I would need to do is put
them back into this original function
and get a y value now I didn't bring a
calculator with me uh it's somewhere in
a bag but I could really quickly put
these in so I'm going to go e to the^ of
Pi 4 this is the first
one times s of Pi on 4 hm these are
gross numbers I really do need a
calculator for this one
so well okay well that's that's one on
root two but this I got no idea what
that is an exact form yeah sure um
though I can leave this in exact form
for this answer for now so it's that
divided by < tk2 there's one and then I
would do the other one 5 Pi on 4 don't
need this equals much the same
thing s of 5 piun on 4 that's going to
be the negative
isn't it so it will actually be negative
e to the blah blah blah blah blah some
exact stuff that my calculator will
worry about now this actually is the
answer for this part of the question so
I've got all the numbers that I need
I'll just highlight
them Pi on 4 matches with that number
which looks messy but don't be
intimidated by it and then 5 Pi on 4
matches with this number these are the
coordinates of the stationary points
that part one but uh this won't cut it
for part two or Part B I should say it
says I need to draw a picture I've been
drawing pictures all the way through
this right but these are kind of like
pieces of the puzzle as it were it's
like I've got the different jigsaw
pieces I need to fit them together and
work out what the entire picture looks
like to do that I really do need to know
what these numbers are so I going to
calc but you've got one don't you do you
want to okay what did we get for the
first one did you already work that one
I haven't done that do you want you go
ahead and work out some numbers um
because then we can start to piece
together this is part B now what this
thing looks like so I'm going to draw
it like
so okay and I might in fact just while
you're doing that I am G to I think I've
got one
here all right you do the first one I'll
do the second one no you're fine
uh it as well so that's that's okay you
can just give me a decimal when once you
get there so the first one is
0.32
0.322 yeah interesting what'd you get
for the other one oh you you haven't
done that one yet I'll give it a go
that's oh I see yeah okay I'm following
I think so it's going to be quite small
it's going to be quite small where's my
e one's just a minus is it uh it'll be
smaller no be smaller cuz look it's
-54 yeah so you might have already
changed the numbers for
me so just as we're doing this part here
what's worth noticing is that um a lot
of the laborious like the part that
looks intimidating and messy to someone
who doesn't have a mathematics
background me working out what this is
or getting a number out that's that's
this thing doing some work not this
right so I'm almost there at an answer
0.139 yeah me
too uh whoops did you say 139 that's
what I got
139 so these are teeny tiny numbers so
I'm going to have to draw this on my
scale as accurately as I can
so no no it's um yeah cuz there there is
actually it's a bit funny because they
have provided um this on the page which
wasn't done in hsc's of the past which
is why you know an HSC of the past my
brain If instinctively went to draw it
but they've actually had that provided
to them which is a bit of a clue but
anyhow um I need a reasonable scale on
this because this is like 30 times
bigger than this number so it's going to
be quite hard to do this accurately but
anyway let's do my best so here's 2 pi
here's Pi there's Pi on 2 there's Pi on
four so there's my first one there and
roughly the same amount of distance
that's 5 Pi on four a trained expert
would have drawn that above the AIS
rather than below CU I know this is
below the axis okay so I'm eyeballing
this is going to have to be like way up
here yeah all right so I've put some x's
here what these X's indicate is the
information I got from completing part A
of the question this x represents this
piece of information that I got and this
x represents the other piece of
information so I'm kind of like all
right I'm going through there I'm going
through there I've kind of turned this
puzzle into like a DOT to dot almost I'm
like where am I going to go through here
okay now I need to know where I start
and where I
finish so if I put not into here
sin0 is zero so I actually don't care
what this is it's just going to go
through here I'm making more dots for
myself the more dots I've got the easier
it is to piece it all together what else
should I put in here I should probably
put Pi cuz that's also s of Pi is also
zero so I've got another X here um s of
2 pi is also zero so I've got that spot
there I feel like this is enough
actually for me now the reason why I
know this is enough is because in part A
I was trying to find where are the
places that see how this thing turns
around it like Wiggles up and down so in
part A I went and I found that there are
two of them only
two here and here so this is like a high
one a mountain this one's a low one a
valley so I know it's not going to
wiggle around anywhere else when I
completed part A I only found it wiggled
twice wiggle is the technical term by
the way so I'm going to do my best to
dot to dot this shape and I'll admit
that is a weird looking shape it's uh
it's not common it's not common to see
something like that
but I could in fact I've got I've got it
on my phone so let's go ahead and see if
I can draw
this it's true like that's how nerdy can
you get okay oh check this out this is
not bad how we looking not bad at all
okay so beautiful there's the graph I'm
actually going to I'll hold this up here
I wonder if that's going to snap into no
I put on manual focus so it's not let's
fix that shall we